foreign
with healing headstones I'm going to
walk you through how I scrape scrub and
deep clean moss covered headstones
assessing the stone and make sure
especially if it's older to if it can
handle a deep cleaning the dirtiest
parts are the very base at the ground or
also deep in the letters
the letters seem to hold on to the most
dirt and grime because they're cut into
the stone most of the newer stones are
made of either marble or Granite they
have more of a glossy finish the stones
before the 20s they don't have if they
did have gloss that's not there anymore
so I think that's why they get stained
way worse and it's way deeper into the
stone
the first thing I do is spray down the
stone with water to make the moss
removal easier I use a hand pump sprayer
to wet the headstones and also to spray
them off
foreign
top to bottom because that's the easiest
method and you can see on the bottom
layers of moss it turns into almost a
concrete like material which makes it
even harder to get off and remove it I
use a special scraper it's kind of the
plastic and a rubber fill at the same
time so it's made for headstones
I'll use the corner of the scraper to
get into the small crevices and remove
any other debris
now when you're using the scraper you
have to be careful of the condition of
the stone and some of them they can have
what's called sugaring where it's almost
as you touch it it'll turn into a powder
same thing with cracks and the same
thing with you know stability with a
scraper you're not really trying to get
all the Moss you're just trying to get
the top layer off without damaging the
stone you want to remove as much Moss as
possible so it's easier when you start
scrubbing the stone
the black is mold and Moss kind of build
up it can also be green sometimes you'll
see orange but that's more they have the
metal rods holding the stone and that's
where water's gotten on the inside and
it the rust starts to run out and that
can stain them as well sometimes you can
scrape the Moss off and you can find
mold underneath which a stained it black
or green into the stone I'd say the moss
on the stone has been built up for a
minimum five years environment and
deployment can both have an effect on
the growth that's on the stone
the finish of the stone can affect kind
of how much growth on it what grows on
it the rougher finishes can hold water
and it holds algae and stuff that builds
up
which kind of just eventually will take
over the stone with a smooth surface
even like the rain can wash away the
growth or anything it starts to build up
up there before it ever takes a hold
[Music]
once all the Moss and debris up a stone
I spray down the stone with D2 cleaner
after I let the spray cleaning solution
set for about 10 minutes I'll follow
that up with a soft bristle brush I
found that using a circular pattern is
the best method
foreign
can vary depending on the stone design
and the Engravings on the front of the
stone I'll sometimes use a toothbrush to
get down into the smaller crevices it
just helps them more thoroughly get all
the debris and things out of the small
places
I'll use a wooden pick to go inside the
letters and some of the engraving if
it's a deep small area that the brush
you can't really get into
to get it back to its original stator as
close as you can sometimes you have to
do certain parts of the process over and
over
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'll do a final spray off to make sure
all the debris is off the stone I
finished the cleaning with a protective
coating of the cleaner because it
continues to keep anything from growing
or building up on the stone I would
recommend checking a stone at least once
every six months minimum to make sure
nothing has started building up before
it gets to an excessive level
[Music]
it's rewarding to be able to help these
families and also honor those whose
graves are unmaintained
foreign